this is james clapper the Director of
the NSA he was at the Senate what was at
the not Foreign Relations the Armed
Services Committee hearing on the NSA
and he gave us a whopper what I wanted
to see is if you could give me a yes or
no answer to the question does the NSA
collect any type of data at all on
millions or hundreds of millions of
Americans no sir it does not not
wittingly ah there are cases where they
could inadvertently perhaps collect but
not not wittingly alright so we've we've
talked about this many times you know
that's right out of Seinfeld when you're
lying the higher up on your head that
you touch that means it's a bigger ly ly
pretty much nailed that one right there
we now know this is a hundred percent
lie he was under oath right there when
he did that uh is this the biggest lie
of the year for sure that's gotta be the
biggest line weld I think of course it's
the biggest lie because you saw how hard
he was punished right after he said that
right but after he said that they
immediately gave him a raise yeah and
they gave him a promotion so now he's in
charge I don't know what exact position
is but he's in charge of everybody again
well he's doing he's like running the
committee that's Kosan review the whole
problem in the first place after I lied
about it the guy all he did was lie to
Congress was a big deal yes but there
but they blame Senator Ron Wyden for
that they say that's his fault because
he should have asked that question he
can't that guy's not supposed to be at
so that's what that's how we got around
lying to Congress Steve you've any
sympathy for a guy that was asked the
question that maybe you shouldn't have
been asked on being slightly sorry
lastly is I i I'm outraged by the story
in fact I'm so outraged I can't make any
jokes about it because it's please it's
ridiculous so James clapper headed NSA
was formerly an executive at booz allen
hamilton yeah and now and what do they
do they have a no-bid contract to
provide data mining services for the NSA
he's an amazing and happy coincidence
they're all involved so when the story
first broke I said immediately to jank
uh I bet you any amount of money that
this is not really about our security or
even or even about spying on Americans
this is really about money someone's
making a lot of money off of this yeah I
guarantee that's why this is happening
and very quickly we found out yes is all
at booz allen hamilton so uh so clapper
is now um you know head of NSA and he
and he was at forum executive at at booz
allen booz allen's current executive was
a former NSA guy since a revolving door
and and and for these guys to say yes
possibly probably unwittingly i don't
know maybe come on I mean it makes a
mockery of the whole system and if you
can get away with these lies that impact
all Americans essentially then it's hard
to take government seriously it's hard
to take the rule of law seriously and it
does breeds contempt for the whole
process yeah so I want to talk about the
the bigger part of that day you're
getting too but just lastly with the lie
itself why are there no repercussions if
you were to lie under oath in a murder
trial you know to me there are
repercussions why are these people held
with totally because he is lying in the
protection of power he's not he's not
lying when he's trying to screw over
power he's lying to protect them so they
all go eyes she's helping what he's
helping us so it's okay and it's okay if
you lie and you're on our side that's
basically it yeah and but if you lie
about come on a dress or getting a
[ __ ] in a hallway of the Oval Office
much worse it we're gonna have to
impeach you if you lie about actually at
the most important the Constitution and
then that's okay yeah so speaking to the
bigger issues that you mentioned there
has Obama sort of been let off the hook
with this thing because it seems like
this whole thing has happened it's
happened obviously it started under
george w bush but it's happened on
Obama's watch too and nobody really
associates him with that because you
have all these clowns like clapper that
make such ridiculous statements
to be honest I don't know and you know
I'm a harsh Obama critic but on this yes
I wish I wish he were more of a leader I
wish he would take the position hey not
on my watch we're not going to have this
we're not going to violate the
Constitution we're not going to waste
taxpayer money we're going to do the
right thing but to be honest I don't
think any president to be honest is
really in charge of this whole apparatus
that's been you know built over decades
of national security and defense because
god forbid if anything happened all
fingers point to a bomb you know what
Obama because you stopped a spying on
Americans now we have we have this
terror strike so blood is on your hand
right so it doesn't that show a huge
flaw in our system that I totally agree
with you the president I don't know how
much he knew or how much he doesn't know
her how much they let him be privy to
purposely because they don't want it
getting all the way up to him so he
can't get in trouble for it but does
that show a flaw in the system if the
President himself can't control these
types of things well I don't you know I
don't know whether he can or the flaw in
the system is that everybody goes along
I think that's the flaw in the system
including the media seem to go along and
less it directly affects them then they
get really pissed about hey you're
tapping our phone where the [ __ ] yeah
but if you tab everyone's phone well in
the end anyway so nobody really cares
about that stuff so is there a flawless
system I think there's a flaw in the
overall system that the people who are
the watchdog's for our society are now
co-opted by the people are supposed to
be watching and so that's why things
like this happen that's why you can uh
cut food stamps at the same time if
you're giving doctors raises in the same
bill right so uh that we need a watchdog
and that's why we're here don't forget
corn subsidies I love that's right corn
so that's my big like other thing to the
reason why I don't blame Obama even more
than I want to blame him on this NSA
issue is that there is no real public
outrage either it's only the far right
the far left yeah upset yes the vast
majority people seem to be like ah
whatever privacy ish minus e whatever we
don't care there's no outcry from the
media because you need to have all
I to empower the President to put a stop
to something that's been going on for so
long you can't just do it on his own
because he could be wrong he's not and
this present is not the leader that's
what that that's gonna make that kind of
bold right that this is not step this is
not him he's a consensus-builder he's a
he's a bureaucrat in many ways and and
he's not going to be that guy who says
we're gonna go in my direction pull
every one mile in my way he's not that
guy yeah and without the outrage just
won't happen so final thought on this so
obviously we have to bring up Edward
Snowden what should happen to him now
because that seems to be the debate now
is you know is he going to stay in
Russia forever is he going to maybe make
it to Brazil we have all these fools I
think like Dianne Feinstein's anxious
you know he should come back here and
face whatever face the music is there
any chance he comes back here should he
come back here I I don't think so I
don't know why you wouldn't trust a
system that you just expose for being
completely corrupt to judge you and why
are you exposing them was okay or not
why wouldn't you why well I don't
understand you know yeah why doesn't why
don't we let the KKK once you go back
and have them give you a trial see if
you're really black or not yeah I mean
what I don't know if that's the craziest
thing that people said why don't you
come back here and take your love what
are you [ __ ] nuts I wouldn't do first
I won't even have done what he did what
he did was heroic right and of course
they don't want they don't want any of
the truth to come out and if that the
worst thing the only thing worse than
doing with James clapper did is doing
with Jay Edward Snowden did which is
actually telling the truth right and
that sort of when uh don't I saw it on
CNN but Jeffrey Toobin who's
consistently been wrong about that
completely wrong on this and he wants uh
Snowden to come back and face the music
yet at the same time is saying that the
the things that he's revealed it's good
we know it but the guy should be in jail
yelling yes which which makes no sense
so what would you agree with that yeah
absolutely i mean the idea that that you
are in the belly of the beast and you
know all the abuses that are happening
you know that they're spy on americans
in violation of the Fourth Amendment you
know that there are indefinite
detentions you know that people are
being extra rendition I mean not that
I fear that they're not what meant well
maybe maybe they will torture us not
into because look what they did to
Bradley Manning yet so just dies in jail
yeah you know there's a there's an
unfortunate accident yeah whatever may
be asking Snowden to submit himself to
all to this system that has done all of
this is freaking insane yeah it's great
it's just not true I mean bar I mean
Diane Feinstein doesn't have she does
have the courage to face one tenth of
what Snowden um would be facing if you
came back to the United States yet the
people who are in charge of protecting
us like Dianne Feinstein and Mike Rogers
the head of the Congressional
intelligence with it they're not there
they're co-opted by the people are
supposed to be regulating yeah so I
imagine the following would happen to
Snowden they'll strip naked they'll put
him in a jail cell though oh yeah I've
mostly what about suicide watch yourself
to Brad yes exactly what they did and
then and then they will destroy his
character yes you know you you literally
go insane if you you're sleep deprived
for too long and you know the bright
lights the cold floors whatever it may
be right you know he has a piss himself
and [ __ ] himself and get mean just
torture and then when he wasn't said i
sees a crazy person yeah crazy but their
toll but again let's always remember
that the point of torture isn't to
extract information it's to get you to
say something they want you to say and
what they wanted bradley manning chelsea
manning to say was that Julian Assange
and him were in cahoots so they they
could go alien songs right so chilly
signs wasn't in cahoots with matt
bradley manning then and he's just being
a journalist which is what he was